(upbeat jazz music)
- Hi, so cute!
- Oh, thank you!
- Your poor parents must
be so disappointed in you.
- Are you even old enough to drive?
- Well, there goes any
chance of fun in your life.
- Do your parents watch him all the time?
- Oh, so you're babysitter?
- Aw, so is he your little brother?
- Oh my God, you're
just like Gilmore Girls.
- So, how are you
supposed to have a career?
- Oh, are you still with the dad?
- Are you with the mom?
- Are you getting any
financial assistance?
- You must hate not being
able to party every weekend.
- But you're just a baby yourself!
- Is that really the way you think
adults are supposed to speak?
But what do I know, I'm just a kid, right?
Have a nice day.